foreign
and I also thank the other organizers
who are running the semester long
program and uh Balu told me that since
this is after lunch everybody's sleepy
and he asked me not to wake him up in
case he falls asleep so what I what I
decided to do is I want to make sure you
guys don't go to sleep so I'll keep
pausing in between for questions and
feel free to stop anytime because this
is supposed to be a tutorial so I don't
have to cover everything but uh let's
make it interactive
I can give you a quiz I can make some
problems on the Fly
uh okay so uh the title is very long I'm
not going to parse it uh it'll become
clear as we go along but two words I
want to highlight stochastic
approximation and reinforcement learning
so the part one of the tutorial that I'm
going to talk about will be completely
unstochastic approximation I'm not going
to talk about reinforcement learning at
all and
zaiway in his part is going to use the
results that I present from the from the
first part and the present results on
reinforcement attorney
so this is uh my part of the talk is
basically joint work with uh it's from
two different pieces of work one is
joint work with zaiway uh Karthik and
Sanjay Sanjay is also here in the
audience and the other work the second
work is uh joint work with Ziva and
Martin who was my former postdoc uh who
is currently at University of Minnesota
and uh Martin might be joining us
remotely at some point I don't know if
he's already there
uh okay let's uh jump into my part of
the tutorial so what I'm going to talk
to you today about is simply this
problem I I want to solve a fixed Point
equation so X is a d dimensional Vector
I only live in Rd uh finite dimensional
spaces and F Bar is an operator it's a
weird notation with a bar you'll see why
later so what's an operator it takes a
vector spits out a vector now all I want
to do is find a vector that solves this
equation a fixed point of this operator
and
um obviously to do this we need to have
some properties on fbar and it's known
classically that if you just keep
applying this F Bar start from your
favorite x0 and keep applying F Bar then
this iteration converges to a fixed
point if F Bar is a contraction this is
called Bannock fixed Point here so
Banana fix Point theorem first
guarantees that there is a fixed point
and then it says that if F Bar is a
contraction you converge to it
geometrically fast the geometric
convergence is also called linear
convergence in optimization literature
and can't contraction just means that
you take your favorite two vectors X and
Y and apply F Bar to those vectors then
the distance decreases by a factor of
gamma less than one gamma is always less
than one gamma is my contraction Factor
so if you have two vectors and you apply
this operator you get two new vectors
sorry this should we have F Bar you get
two new vectors and the distance has
contacted
and uh fixed Point theorem does not care
about what the underlying Norm is it
could be any normal Rd and banox Theorem
is applicable even in infinite
dimensional spaces we'll see that in our
case the role of the norm is going to be
very important
uh so actually everything that he said
in terms of contraction works even for
pseudo contractions
um sorry everything I said in terms of
convergence works also for pseudo
contraction what's the pseudo
contraction this is the same equation as
before except that instead of Y I put x
x star and if bar of X star is X star so
I replaced X star here and pictorially
what this is saying is that you have X
star you have your X if you apply again
this should be F Bar if you apply F Bar
uh the distance to X star is decreasing
the distance to some other arbitrary why
I don't know so this is this is a
generalization uh when you have pseudo
to define a pseudo contraction you need
a x star but the contraction implies
existence of X star and pretty much
everything I'm going to talk about today
also applies for pseudo contraction but
I'll just focus on the contraction for
this talk
okay now it's it gets interesting
everything I said so far is classical
now the problem is I want to run this
banark iteration but uh I don't have
access to fbar I have an access to a
nosy noisy Oracle so I give it x k its
job is supposed to give me F Bar of x k
but it's going to add some noise in the
process and the noise can actually it
can be IID or it can depend on XK we'll
talk more about the noise model later
now the question is what do I do now
should I just pretend as if this or
noise and just keep doing this iteration
and almost yes turns out you can keep
doing that but it's good it's a good
idea to introduce a step size so what is
the steps what this is saying is that
earlier banak just went to F Bar of x k
what we are doing now is I'm at XK
instead of going all the way to F Bar of
x k plus noise which the Oracle is
suggesting me to go to I'll do a convex
combination
and this convex combination weights can
change with time the idea is that if I
know I am somehow closer to the optimum
then maybe I don't want to trust this
Oracle too much because it's noisy so I
want to put less weight on it as I go
along so over time maybe I want to
decrease this Alpha case and the same
thing can be Rewritten like this x k
plus 1 equal to x k plus step size times
F Bar of x k plus noise minus x k
the main question I'm going to address
in the stock is does this work
uh and the answer is supposed to be yes
otherwise I'll not be talking to you how
well does this work that's the I want to
characterize the rates of convergence
and
um uh I'll tell about what that means in
the next slide so this is the outline of
my talk I'm going to uh first introduce
stochastic approximation we we are
currently Midway through the
introduction then I'm going to talk
about rates of convergence uh finite
sample bounds uh I'll do this in a mean
Square sense x k is now random iteration
because the or because of the noise from
the Oracle I look at the distance square
the square is not important you could uh
you could get rid of the square if you
don't like it but essentially it's
expectation of the mean error and I'll
present a sketch of the proof uh it's a
Lia proof I'll talk about what the
lapino function is and so on and after
that I'm going to talk about high
probability bounds from this x k minus X
star on the error uh that that I want to
be exponentially decaying and then also
if time permits I'll also present uh
proof sketch of that result as well um
some of you in the audience may have
seen this part of my talk but then I
want to tell you that this part is brand
new it's so new it's just off the oven
it's not even published yet but uh the
paper is going to be out in a couple of
weeks
I mean it's not even on archive yet
publishing area takes long time
okay so let's continue talking about
sarcastic
um so again this is the equation I want
to solve this is stochastic
approximation algorithm that we already
saw I want to motivate it from using
several examples let's start with
optimization uh any questions so far
okay uh let's start with optimization I
have a function this is not an operator
no it's a function it's a scalar valued
function I'm going to find an X that
minimizes this and uh let's say this is
convex then this is same as saying I
want to solve gradient of f equal to 0
and I'm writing that equation in a funny
manner I just added x's on both sides
and I put a ETA here if I solve this
equation that will be the minimum of f
of x now this starts looking like uh my
fixed Point equation where my operator
is basically this guy
uh and it can be shown that if f is
smooth strongly convex for an
appropriate choice of ETA uh this
operator is indeed a contraction with
respect to L2 node so indeed if I prove
some result on stochastic approximation
I can immediately apply it on
optimization but that's not required
because optimization oh sorry uh when I
don't have noise this uh when I when you
don't have access to exact gradients and
I have noisy gradients then the
stochastic approximation algorithm
reduces to SGD basically I have a bar of
x minus X that X cancels with this so
I'll end up with simply a gradient of f
the Theta is absorbed into my step size
um so by far the most popular form of
stochastic approximation that's studied
is SGD and many of the results I talk
about today are uh well known in the
case of SGD but not all the results I
think the first part is well known the
second part I'm not quite sure if some
of the results are known even in the
case of SGD and so this way of modifying
optimization into fixed Point might look
little bit silly but turns out there are
many ways of translating optimization
into finding fixed points of operators
and this connection can be used to
actually formulate many optimization
algorithms in terms of fixed points
Solutions so this is a recent book by
what are we in and Ernest true where
they talk about many optimization
algorithms from operator methods so uh
that's one example
then the second example is uh on is from
reinforcement learning this is what XIV
is going to talk about in the second
part of the tutorial so I'll not dwell
much upon this uh but here F Bar is
going to be my Bellman operator and in
mdps or reinforcement learning I want to
solve a Bellman equation which is a
fixed Point equation of this form and if
we take this stochastic approximation
all the return most of the popular uh
reinforcement running algorithms like TD
learning Q learning can essentially be
thought of as some variance of the
stochastic approximation approach and
turns out that the corresponding
operators here the underlying Norms uh
can be very different for TD one can
show that it's a contraction with
respect to weighted LP Norm for various
values of P for all P from 2 to Infinity
but whereas for Q learning uh it's a ll
Infinity non-contraction so uh so
various Norms that show up play an
important role in my talk I am going to
present results that work for all Norms
so more details about reinforcement
learning will be in the second part of
the talk
um
I'm not quite sure maybe Java knows
something about how when when treaty was
discovered uh did they think of it as
Robin's murder
I mean it's
the fixed Point situation
definitely is something really was
discovered without any mention of yes
just like
painting
yeah in fact it was thought of as like
some kind of optimization algorithm
where you drop sometimes and so on I
guess no it was like there was a story
underlying it it was like oh you need to
boost that you use your own predictions
that's the TV errors instead of like in
supervised learning you're trying to
predict the value to take the difference
to the value and your tracks based on
the difference here the error has its
own prediction you because you don't
know the future values yeah but you can
predict them why not like you ultimately
plugins that's a sense it's in the book
caused this optimistic character
speaking of this because there's a
prediction that is
shouldn't has no reason to be correct
you plug it in it still works
it's kind of like pretty neat
yeah that's right but I think the
connection is made at some point I think
it was already well known by 90s in the
neurodynamic programming book they talk
about yeah it's early 90s connection
with me
start device connection to DP and then
on this direction
yeah
the convergence is based on Instagram
okay so the third example I want to give
you is a is a following linear equations
x equal to B and again I'm again making
some silly manipulations to make it look
like this I multiply both sides by ETA
uh bring this one to the left side and
then add X on both sides I end up with
this now this starts looking like this
and my operator is basically whatever
you see on the left hand side and turns
out that if a is Horowitz Horowitz just
means that the real part of all the
eigen values is less than zero if a were
a symmetric Matrix this is same as
negative definite but if when a is not
submitted negative definiteness is
different from symmetric matrices when a
is not symmetric I only care about the
real part and it can be shown that as
long as survey's property is satisfied I
can find a ETA under which this whole
thing will be a contraction I mean this
is just affine term so this is almost
irrelevant but this Matrix operator and
Matrix are the same thing in the linear
case this Matrix or the operator will be
a contraction with respect to some
weighted electron
and then if I write stochastic
approximation in this case again this is
my F Bar operator this x here this is a
minus X here they cancel off and I
essentially end up doing this and uh um
uh um okay one thing I want to point out
is what is the source of noise here I
want to solve this equations here I am
pretending that b is unknown and I get
some samples b k whose mean is B then I
have this update then I can also ask the
question about what if a is unknown here
uh I'm pretending a is known and that's
what I'll talk about in the next slide
and linear stochastic approximation
Works in both cases
um uh so in fact I was told that uh the
many many ways of solving uh I mean I
know that there are many many ways of
solving linear equations but I was told
that if you have large uh number of
equations like in machine learning like
TD learning and so on then uh one of the
most popular ways today is to basically
do this this is this can be thought of
as some variant of HTT
uh okay good so
any questions so far
in this slide I'm going to present my
formulation more formally so I want to
solve F Bar of x equal to X and my
operator F Bar actually if I dig into it
there's more going on what I have is a
mapping F uh it's a it's a it takes two
things X and Y not just X alone and Y
for me is a markup chain
um and F Bar is simply an expectation of
this with respect to the stationary
distribution of my mark actually let's
actually make this concrete so in this
case the corresponding stochastic
approximation it looks same as before
but instead of f instead of just F Bar
of X here I am writing f of x comma y so
earlier I had W as my noise now I'm
introducing a second source of noise I
could have combined everything and then
called it a modeled it as a single
Source but that's the reason why I'm
splitting it into two forms and if we
think of it as uh think of the special
case of linear stochastic approximation
my f of x comma y can be thought of as a
k times x so instead of Y I have a k a k
is also no I see here and this should be
b k my w k additive noise w k can be
thought of as my B so y k is I call it
multiplicative noise inspired by the
special case and W as my additive noise
here it is beginning
uh so the way they affect the iterate
are different uh and that's the reason I
want to make this distinction and when I
actually start modeling them I also
allow different behavior on both of them
and some of these assumptions are
inspired by what shows up in
reinforcement learning so I assume YK is
a finite State ergotic marker chain
whose stationary distribution is new a
special case of that would be y case IID
with distribution View and uh one
consequence of finite state ergotic is
that YK is geometrically mixing so the
distribution of y k approaches its
stationary distribution geometrically
fast if you don't like Markov chain just
pretend it to be IID for the purpose of
my talk XIV would worry about the Markov
chain in his part of the talk and the
additive noise WK uh if you want to keep
it simple think of it as ID more
generally it can be Martingale
difference uh martial difference just
means that it has conditional mean zero
it can depend on the history in complex
ways
um and WK can also depend on x k and
it's bounded
in this manner so if x k grows w k can
grow but uh the support WK is random
think of it as its support is bounded in
this manner so this bond is Almost sure
and finally everybody's contraction and
I want to highlight that it's a
contraction with respect to an arbitrary
now
any questions about the formulation
yes
why not faster
um so this linear assumption is almost
like here if a k is some bounded random
variable then the noise that's generated
by this is like uh some B times escape
so I'm allowing something like that here
but if it is faster if it's quadratic
then the noise can kind of Shadow out
the main nitrate so I want to so usually
in exact word people will Pretend This
is a constant I'm relaxing it to be
linear and okay but the honest reason
why I know people do this is because
this is
it just works
and this alarm has to be the same
very good question so in finite
Dimensions all Norms are equal which
means you can go from one log to another
you'll introduce just a constant but the
contractions under different Norms are
not equivalent if you change the norm
here you should introduce a constant and
here and here and those Concepts
together may go above one and you may
not have a contraction so when I Define
a contraction the wrong is very very
important but here else is there is some
big constant here you can work in which
our Norm you want and absorb the other
things in this concept uh but still your
question is valid because if you if I
start jumping around between the Norms
the constants I get have dimensional
Independence uh here I think for the
purposes of the talk I'm just assuming
they are the same Concepts
okay so now I'm moving into the results
in the first part of the talk on means
to advance so uh I'll just jump right
into the results so at first I'll focus
on the case for the step size is a
constant uh and uh this is all same so
this is some condition I mean my results
you should all think of these as like uh
uh
simplified forms of the theorem so I'm
hiding so many things under the carpet
all the constants are not really
constants that depend on certain problem
parameters and the dependencies
explicitly presented in the paper but if
the step size is small enough is
essentially what we have is that the
mean square error converges to zero
forget about this log term for the time
being so what you have is something less
than one power K so it's going to zero
geometrically fast and the second part
there's a constant again forget about
the log term for the time being and this
constant essentially depends on my step
size so the picture is basically that I
start somewhere far away very quickly
geometrically fast I'm approaching X
star after some point I'm not making any
progress I'm just uh wandering a
wandering around and this is inevitable
Whenever there is a constant step sense
because this noise is not letting me
converge anywhere and the log Alpha
terms show up mainly because I'm
assuming uh markovia noise if I had
iodine noise these logs would not be
there because I have geometric mixing I
have these lock terms and by the way
geometric mixing can be relaxed little
bit you need to have fast enough mixing
it can be polynomial of large enough
power I forget if it is two or three and
then these would change accordingly
uh so only in this theorem I'll
highlight some dependencies I'm hiding
the initial condition typically shows up
here and usually people call this as an
optimization error at least in
optimization world and this is
statistical error uh I like to call it
bias and variance
um so this term shows that if you did
not have noise at all this would be your
rate which is geometric which we knew
from bannock's theorem and because of
noise you are getting this rate with
essentially this theorem is saying you
don't even have convergence
because of the traditional Alpha term
and I also want to highlight that our
result is true for any norm and certain
factors that depend on the norm are
hiding in my C1 C2 C3 and I want to show
what happens in the spatial case of L
Infinity Norm contractions because among
all LP Norms these are the hardest in to
analyze once you understand the behavior
for L Infinity Norms generalizing it to
all the Norms was pretty straightforward
at least in our approach and so suppose
you had L Infinity Norm contraction uh
then this would be one minus gamma over
two gamma is my contraction factor and
most importantly this is going to be log
D if you had two Norm contraction there
wouldn't be any dimensionality
dependence here but if you have Infinity
Norm contraction there's a logarithmic
dependence in dimensionality and we
believe this is not an artifact of a
proof I think it's fundamental because
Infinity Norm is like Max and these are
all random Max of D gaussians is like
log D so we should expect a log D
somewhere yes
food for all nonsense YouTube
yes uh mixing uh
yeah I mean you can go from one room to
the other using a constant so if your
geometric means for all the cases
but uh
L at least like you don't need mixing
you don't need to have mixes
nope
so it's
oh that's what you mean I see okay
um
so here I'm not even thinking of that
here basically I'm ensuring that my f of
x comma Y is close to F Bar
so I don't even have the discounted
setup here that comes
no no I mean later we're going to use it
for discounted reward but uh we use the
geometric mixing to essentially argue
that this F Bar is close to f of x comma
yeah
maybe what you're thinking about today
collect the examples in such a way that
the mixing doesn't even apply right
but if you just have accidentally in the
collection and you just have this data
screen I know that comes from the Marco
chain I don't see how you can get away
without some sort of mixing distance
you only care about whatever Horizon but
even within that Horizon the samples
that you get needs to be somehow close
to the stationary distribution or
whatever the solution you want to do and
mixing is useful but it's in this option
to just have internet
um
Association
[Music]
I mean if you only care about asking
that takes them you're not going to see
mixing with that
I'm like the biggest thumbs are not
going to be appear in the assembly
finite uh infinity contraction case this
is the only difference
and the Simon's dependence on the
initial conditions
pretty much because this is clear here
but like I still like maybe we can
discuss applied but I'm not sure if you
need like
convergence
overlapping
with me so I'm assuming fire at States
so always
trademark options if you have existence
Association of distribution pretty much
okay
okay so one can use even this to get
sample complexity so if I say that my
main square error oh yeah so if you have
a sort of anonymously terrorism and you
know if the error is somehow going to
zero as is K goes to Infinity do we get
a similar result or
I guess my question is how fast you know
does that need to go to Geo I see I
think we can we haven't thought about it
but essentially this uh marker reality
is going to give some terms like that
here we are assuming geometry uh but
geometric is not required if you have
like I don't remember the exact uh
dependence but one of K square of cube
or four something like that then I think
it should not matter that's my that's my
gut reaction and stochastic error that
goes with yes definitely got reaction
but I'm not 100 sure we have to look at
the teachers thank you
um so I'm saying that suppose someone
tells me that uh I want to give them a
guarantee that this error is less than
Epsilon then what I would do is I would
put my step size small enough so that
this is like Epsilon over 2 and I would
wait till this becomes Epsilon over two
and that gives me my sample complexity
and if you do the calculation you'll get
a sample complexity of O of 1 over
Epsilon Square tilde just means that I'm
hiding log factors
um uh so what this says is that by
picking steps are small enough I can
make error as small as I want but if I
run it for this many iterations I'll get
error Epsilon but if I run it longer I'm
not going to make any Improvement
because in constant substance I can't
make any Improvement
uh so then uh if I want asymptotic
convergence if I if I want a good Ray
but also eventually go to zero I have to
use diminishing step sizes or I could
decrease step sizes in some adaptive
manner looking at my eye trades I'll
just focus on the diminishing steps in
this case and uh here I'll focus on the
case when step sizes of the form some
constant divided by K power and exponent
and this exponent is supposed to be
between 0 and 1. if it's zero we get
constant set size case from the previous
slide and if it is more than one turns
out you may not even go to x star
because if it is more than one the total
radius total distance you can travel
starting from X zero will be bounded if
your X star is outside you can never
reach it so we'll only consider the case
when this is between 0 and 1 and I again
have both these optimizational
stochastic terms in the uh rate earlier
remember this the worst term the second
term was a constant it was not even
going to zero now this is going to zero
and I'm only showing the second term I'm
showing the dominant term here I'm just
observing everything else E4
but the main thing is that this log
again comes because of geometry the
marker mixing if it is ID this would be
a one and uh
um but the main thing is that I cannot
allow a site to be equal to one in this
case but if we want the best rate I want
side to be as large as possible so the
natural site to work with is one so it
turns out when PSI equal to one that is
one more case step sizes step size case
you should be very careful with the
constant Alpha in this case this Alpha
is almost Irrelevant this Alpha is
sitting somewhere in the constant the
rate is not affected by Alpha but in the
one hour case step size case Alpha can
affect the rate Alpha should be large
enough in which case you get what you
expect you expect putting PSI equal to 1
here will be the right rate that's what
you get but if Alpha is not large enough
then the rate can be sacrificed
then this phenomena is uh already well
understood in SGD world so pretty much
qualitatively everything I'm talking
about here is known in the case of SGD
our main contribution is to do this for
General Infinity non-condactions
uh again this my initial error uh hiding
there and in the case of infinity Nom uh
uh contraction this is my one minus
gamma over two and the C6 has this log D
here and one is gamma dependence looks
like this
um so this one over K again if I ignore
the logs this one over K corresponds to
a sample complexity of what yield of one
over Epsilon Square uh on the mean error
without the square and the advantage of
this compared to the previous Slide the
sample complexity is the same but the
advantage of this is in the previous
slide I had to tell you Epsilon ahead of
time and then you pick a constant
substance depending on that here I don't
have to tell you anything you just pick
a step size that's uh that satisfies
this condition one over case steps that
satisfies this condition you keep going
after so many iterations you uh your
error is Epsilon if you run longer your
error guarantee will get better and
better so that's the advantage of using
uh diminishing step success the
algorithm by algorithm I mean the update
rule which has step size in it does not
depend on does not depend on your target
error episode
any questions
it's known it's it's actually yeah
uh in optimization people worry about
not knowing it in reinforcement learning
it will just be the Discord factors
foreign
uh okay I'm running out of time so I
think I'll skip this slide I'll jump
right into proof sketch any other
questions before that
we'll just set the office adapted
uh yeah but we don't explore that we
only do whatever like Adam
STD world
it's very messy
um I we can chat off like like
sounds good but what I can tell you is
that our main contribution is some of
the reactor function so if you figure
out how to do SGD for an diagram you can
use a reactor function you'll get a
similar reason for the Adaptive sources
thank you maybe there are things that
might break down but this would be my
initial reaction Sunday is not happy
good
um
was talking about asymptotic convergence
so asymptotic convergence of these
algorithms was done back in the 90s and
one approach is to use the ode method
and uh one can learn about this in the
book by borker we do not use OD method
but I use OD method for inspiration I
basically look at what OD method is
doing and I copy the same step without
following the OD method that's my proof
technique and uh let's first talk about
a real method so the idea is you take
the stochastic approximation send this
one to other side send Alpha K on to the
other side you get this now squint your
eyes wave your hands this looks like a
derivative and since we are squinting
and waving there's no noise so I just
get this and I get this ode and
squinting and waving hands but burka
does not do that he makes this
connection very very formal and he has a
big theorem what is his theorem he says
that if you can prove that this ode can
register is fixed point then under
appropriate choice of Step sizes this
guy also converges to the fixed point
but that's only as a particle
so if you want to use his hammer uh you
have to show this guy converges to his
fixed point and he did that as well and
usually when you have ODS of this form
dynamical systems basically to show
their convergence one would use a
leopard
so the idea is one comes up with a
function and in this case the right
lapino function to study the ode is
infinity Norm square and focusing on the
infinity Norm case for the proof uh just
to be specific and one can show that the
time derivative of this after using
chain Rule and using the ode update one
can show it has this negative reform and
then this converges to its fixed Point
uh geometry it converts to zero
geometrically fast exponentially fast
um and worker would say that that
implies convergence so this done but we
want to get rate of convergence so we
don't follow this approach Shabba has a
question
okay yeah
um
actually the way a worker shows this is
also very interesting he looks at Phenom
so let's we go to Infinity so he does
not face that issue
so
what I want is finite time bombs but I
don't use audience but I want to take
inspiration from it and the main
challenge relative to the ode is that
ode is nice and clean I have my update
that looks like this this is the same
equation as here I added and subtracted
F Bar
this term is a good term this is same as
the Oda term I kind of know how to
handle that inspired by this and but
here I don't have derivative I have
discretization I have to handle that
error here because of marker this is my
markavian error this is where I'm going
to explore geometric mixing and if I had
IAD this error uh would uh oh it would
still be there but it will at least be
mean zero now it's not mean zero it has
a bias and of course I have my additive
myself I'm worried about all the errors
but this is my uh this term I'm happy
and among all these errors that are
scary my good friend is Alpha K which is
going to help us by decreasing Alpha K
over time I'm going to get handle on
these errors okay so let's actually
further think about this what is the ODC
the ode the lyapanov function is
essentially saying that this ode is kind
of trying to minimize this layer product
function that's one interpretation of
leopard no functions so if you have this
lapino function and you follow this OD
you will essentially go to the minimum
very nicely now the stochastic
approximation wants to do that but it is
jumping dancing around because of
discretization and uh and noise now the
question is in spite of it is it going
to be okay
and the answer is it's going to be okay
if your m is smooth uh this is same
definition of smoothness in optimization
um essentially this is saying I can
truncate the Taylor series at second
order with a constant here without the
Hessian and this L is the smallest
Factor if I have something like this
then the errors that are being
introduced here can be captured here and
I can handle them and life will be good
but the only problem is that this
Infinity Norm square is not smooth two
Norm square is both P Norm square is
smooth for p between 2 and Infinity but
Infinity Norm square is smooth that's
the reason I keep saying that infinity
or Norm is the hardest to analyze and so
what I want is okay fine worker came up
with an IC up no function I can't use it
so I'll come up with my only Apple
function and whatever I come up with I
want it to be smooth and since I know
that the correctly upon a function is
this guy whatever I come up with I want
it to be closed close to that guy this
is the approximation property so this is
my wish list if I find a function that
satisfies these two hopefully it might
work I mean I have to do this
approximation in the right way otherwise
it might not work suppose I satisfy
these two then essentially I can write a
recursion like this
um which is the reminiscent of our ode
this is like my difference of the
lyapano function and this is the
negative drift and there'll be some
terms corresponding to this Alpha K and
then once I solve this recursion for
various values of alpha K you will get
the theorems that we talked about
okay so now the question is what is this
leopard function and it's basically take
my correctly open function for the ode
and take my favorite smooth function and
smooth it out so this box operator it
will smooth the whole thing if you have
two convex functions and you apply box
between them the whole thing you get
will be sorry if you have two convex
functions and one of them is smooth
after you do this you'll get a convex
function that's smooth so I can take my
favorite smooth functions and then do
this and my favorite functions are
basically P Norm squares so P between
200 Infinity excluding infinity and when
P when this function is actually two
Norm Square this is called Moro envelope
more generally we call it generalized
more envelope and now what is this box
operator it's called informal
convolution it looks like convolution
except that in convolution you have an
integration here and you have a
multiplication here you replace
integration with Min multiplication with
plus you get informal convolution
um so there's this nice uh once you
think of convolution you should think of
Fourier transforms this nice Duality
between functions therefore you're going
back and forth between these two spaces
similarly there is an essential Duality
between functions and the duals
um and do also for smooth functions are
strongly convex and so on so this is a
very beautiful theory behind it but all
I need is that I apply this smoothing
operator and then I get a nice smooth
function everything works I get bounds
then I'm going to I said I use P Norm
Square I'm going to optimize over p and
mu to get the best possible bounds in
fact optimizing over P gives us the log
d uh dependence for the infinity log
Square
any questions
oh I'm missing a little bit of
connection yeah
like together so what we do is uh we
basically look at the Disco fam we do
something like this think of proof of
optimization of smooth surrounding
convex functions you'll look at
quadratic x k minus X star square is the
apno function so instead of square I use
this m as a lapino function then I have
to use properties of M I have to use I
have to use the smoothness property and
the expression for gradient of M and
then I can get something like this once
I get this I just solve the regression
pretty much that's the reason I was
saying that if you have some proof of
gradient descent at least in principle I
believe we should be able to do we
should be able to generalize it to this
case once you know what the liabino
functions this is the problem in
understanding Infinity Norm uh
stochastic approximation so in the
neurodynamic programming book uh the
authors basically say that Infinity now
this only we don't know the liabner
function
so basically we find the Liga profession
uh so one last word about how to handle
the noise so essentially smoothness is
going to be our friend in handling the
noise and whenever I have these errors
this discretization and additive noise
errors uh so this additive noise error
I'm bounding by x k and then any error
of the form XK I'll use smoothness to
get a handle on it I'll use smoothness
to get a handle on this too for this I
need something more if this was uh if
this was IID its expectation will be
zero and that would have been that would
have made me happy but uh this is not
IID this is Mark avian so the
expectation of this is not zero uh but
what I'm going to do is uh here I'm
going to use markup chain mixing so when
you actually work within the proof
you'll get a cross term of this form if
this was IID you can just simply take
the expectation inside this will become
F Bar the whole thing is zero but when
this is not IID what we do is the
problem is the expectation of this is
not this and not only that this XK is
correlated to y k so you can't simply
pull the expectation inside so what we
do is we condition how time slots away
how is the mixing time so condition on
this this markup chain has mixed so
these are almost independent now you can
pull the expectations inside make this
almost zero and then work with it and
this trick uh this is how I'm explaining
mixing and this trick is it goes back
all the way to bertikas and citicus in
the book uh where they use this for
asymptotic convergence but more recently
it was used by srikanth and ing for
final 10 months
going way slower than I expected but
it's okay
I'll try my best to stop at three I will
not have to cover everything though yeah
no actually in general is everything to
uh the United States as long as they're
Compact and you have fast enough mixing
you don't have any junk in fact we do
that in one of our places
uh so we need the actually when I showed
the assumptions I hid couple assumptions
technical assumptions on the under the
carpet I need some ships properties on
this F and so on because I have this f
of x comma y I want to make sure that
the soup of this does not go to infinity
and things like that
overall values of Y
maybe one can relax it but uh at least
we assume compact
that way do you have anything to say
about it
so I think we have to release it in
terms of X or o y
same difference and the simplest thing
is to take soup over one and then
all right so I have only 15 minutes I'll
at least try to State my tailbounce if I
don't talk about the proof the proof is
quite interesting I'm happy to talk to
anybody offline over there okay so now
the question is so uh this is Microsoft
approximation we have mean sphere box of
this form and if I want now I want
tailbones on this guy I'm not happy with
main Square bombs I want to guarantee
that my error is less than something if
I want that tail bounce I can always
happily use markup in quantity and if
I'm interested in probability like this
I can use marker in quality this cancels
it is that's right when we put the same
thing and then I hit one over Z here but
I'm not happy with this I want
exponential things so essentially what
I'm saying is the mean square is bounded
by this guy now if I want to give high
probability like 99 probability bound I
have to blow it up by something
as far as a function of my block Factor
how does the tail Decay this is the
decay of the tail this is one over Zine
this in this case but uh I want
exponential case because those are like
very fast decaying tails
um and this is the question I want to
explore in this part of my talk
Java seems not happy
all right
this thing
this thing can be written slightly
differently instead of I can call this
guy Delta then this Z becomes log 1 over
Delta n that is this this is the form
we'll be working with going forward
exponential whenever this exponential if
you invert it you'll get long that's
that's all there is to it yes
the expectation of the deviation Square
itself it is okay
summer plan but I guess like you fold it
into
not money you study that Asian
follow our case thing for two things
yeah yeah I combined it to the credit
card normally people look at the
behavior of the mean and the deviation
for the mean I'm not doing that I'm just
combining everything together in fact
that simplifies yeah yeah it's a little
bit true there yes yes yes yes yes
so what Chapel is saying is a property
people ask two questions like if you
look at Van handle's book in the
beginning this is the two questions one
is uh how does the mean of this guy
behave and the second question is this
guy without the mean how far does it
deviate from the mean what I'm saying is
I'm not even making the distinction I'm
just looking at this ads
like the variance of that or yeah yeah
okay okay
pictorially same thing one of those
details looks bad compared to
exponential tail nothing much here the
answer is yes
um and uh ah by the way this means that
if I prove a result like this this means
the sample complexity of this form I
have to pass this now my sample
complexity is in terms of two things
Epsilon and Delta this is like this is
like pack bombs so I want my error to be
less than Epsilon with probability one
minus Delta and then the question is how
many samples do I need uh for that if I
prove a bond like this with this
particular dependence I'll get 1 over
Epsilon square and log 1 over data
uh and that's uh in some sense the best
you can get in this setup okay uh so I
have some slides on related work I think
I'm going to skip this but one thing I
want to say is that if you use constant
step size bad things can happen it was
shown that the stationary distribution
is heavy tailed what this means is that
uh there are large enough moments that
depend on the constant for a given
constant step says maybe there is like
let's say 100 100th moment it keeps
blowing up the 10 and doesn't goes to
Infinity it goes to Infinity so you'll
get heavy tail stationary distributions
which means you cannot get exponential
exponential tail bonds uh uh I'll skip
all of this
and uh and I want to convey to you that
this problem is much much more
challenging than the previous one and I
want to show that in the case of sim uh
linear stochastic approximation so this
is our linear stochastic approximation
let's keep it simple let's say b0
then this is simply x times 1 plus Alpha
a so essentially all I'm doing is I have
a vector I'm repeatedly multiplying it
by a matrix which is this one plus Alpha
a now what do we know about this Matrix
uh when expectation of a is that's all
we know one can show that for the right
choice of alpha when that guy is through
its expectation of this guy is a
contraction
but this guy himself is not a
contraction so what's happening is I
have a vector if I keep applying it
contraction nice things will happen but
I'm applying something a random Matrix
which is in expectation contraction but
in reality sometimes it can even be
expansive so but since in expectation
it's contraction overall you expect good
things to happen but when I say good
things to happen I want a very fine
bound on that in terms of exponential
deal and that turns out to be hard
showing mean Square bounds in this
setting is not that hard we already did
it that's why it's not hard
um uh but tails are heavy so in constant
subsides case you can't show exponential
tails and but there is a recent work
that does tail bounce under constant
step size uh they get exponential Tails
but they assume that all of these guys
are contractions
so that's a very strong assumption
oh for constitution
uh then yeah so I'm saying that about
the season paper they assume that all of
these operators are not actions by the
way this story I'm telling you about
multiplying by contractor versus
expensive that's true more General I
think in a linear case it's very
difficult to see
um then if they don't have that
assumption the real thing and this
expectation is in expectations
contraction and otherwise it's not they
only get polynomial dreams and that's
inevitable we cannot get expensive table
because it's simple uh so we get
expansion rates but we do that with
Dimensions like this and we do it not
for linear this this work is only for
the year we do it for General Conference
okay so this slide is same as before the
assumptions the setup I'm going to
modify it I'm actually going to simplify
it a little bit because it's harder
problem I want to simplify it the first
first thing is I'm not going to look at
all diminishing steps as this I only do
one over K sum of the results in our
paper that's yet to come will be for 1
over K power Z also but uh we'll just
stick with one okay uh so now I'm
throwing away Mark avian uh thing so
Mark again is very important if you want
to use this in RL but that's going to be
future work for this work the paper
that's going to come out we just work
with IID process so with State uh with
stationary distribution mu and I'm also
assuming bonded support in reality I
have a assumption more General than this
think of it as some appropriate
generalization of uh IID to Martingale
but I'll not get into it right now uh
but the boundedness I want to justify it
by saying that if you do not have
boundedness if you go back to linear
stochastic approximation and think of
one dimension so scalar then in three
iterations MGF does not exist in three
iterations it becomes heavy tail so the
bondedness is in some essential to get
to get any dates
my own all my difficulty is with respect
to multiplicative rocks additive noise
is a lot better
multiplicative noise is what makes a
charge
and the contraction property and the
noise assumptions are the same now let
me present the result same setup I just
put one over K here so what I'm saying
now is that if Alpha is large enough the
stepper the numerator thingy is large
enough then I basically give you what I
promised that with probability 1 minus
Delta I have the mean the square error
no mean square error is less than or
equal to 1 over K log 1 over Delta with
with probability
and this gives the sample complexity
that I promised
but there is a catch you know there's a
catch because I have this bracket the
cases so turns out we can show this only
for K large enough Above This log 1 over
Delta and below that we only have a
terrible bound that is growing in k uh
up to this log 1 over Delta the question
is why is this Bond going up at the
beginning why do we need the why is our
nice one over K bound only after some
time
so if I show it to you pictorially this
is what we have uh in terms of log 1
over Delta up to this time our bond is
growing after that it's what we expect
um and so the intuition for this is that
we believe this is inevitable and the
reason is that remember I'm applying by
this Matrix random Matrix that is
expansive sometimes but in expectation
it's contractive which means you need
enough samples for averaging to kick in
to make the overall think contraction
and how many samples you need depends on
how accurately you want a contraction
and that depends on log this one over
data so so because of this we believe
that this initial increasing uh maybe
this Bond can be improved especially it
can be there is a jump here it can
possibly be improved so that there's no
jump but the increase we believe is
inevitable and uh Martin did a
simulation run of 5000 uh uh runs of
scalar case contraction but like the
random thing can be expensive and then
we see that initially it goes up a
little later it goes down
[Music]
is an arbitrary operator that satisfies
this so you can think of the three
examples again either linear or HDD or
uh
the simulation he just did the scale it
so the linear thing linear stochastic
approximation where AK is now a scalar
so he took that AK to be mean point
eight but uh the random things is it
like 0.5 plus gaussian noise times x
that's
something like that I actually have the
exact thing right here so it's uh a 0.8
b0 and
I don't know so I don't know the
randomness though but he ensure to do
something it goes over one so yeah it
has to be body noise
sure all of those need to come out so
like I said this paper is we have the
result we have the theorem proof but
we're still writing the paper if you
don't have the story I think we want to
try and make those dependencies
did this in the case of bellman equation
and then he got one over one men's gamma
for five in some context uh for Q
learning and the five is optimal there
so I don't know what it is in the linear
case
yeah I think it becomes slightly clearer
in the proof which I may not have time
for but uh essentially what I'm saying
is that
um the increase part
um this bound that we get is actually
worst case part so it is possible to
improve this but the increase in is
inevitable because think of it this way
so let's say you are multiplying by this
uh Bernoulli a by Bernoulli I don't mean
Bernal it's not zero one let's say it
takes point five and two with
probability so that the mean is 0.8 okay
so I'm multiplying by this a but uh if
you run it for 10 iterations then there
is non-trivial probability that you just
keep going expand you just keep getting
uh the two and then you are far away
right uh and here we are interested in
the exponential tail so this tail uh the
the one over Delta tail maybe you have
just been uh you're just being
increasing but the longer you run it
average in kickson and then you'll start
uh seeing that it goes yeah
things you shouldn't have these two
things Behavior the two phase should be
stick kicking in because the step size
becomes small enough so that you have
enough averaging before you move and
know you are mostly moving in the right
direction beforehand the step side was
slightly large
but the bound the increase thing comes
up to log 1 over Delta
there's some costs I'm sorry I don't
know
I'm just trying to understand like very
simple argument sound there's
multiplicative
scale uh and like for a while it doesn't
even go to zero fine but eventually it
does go to zero what changed between the
two things like especially because you
know the values are big enough
no they need to decrease because they
eventually go to zero right so it's only
the step size that changed between the
time that we started
it's more than that because we're
interested in the tail probability so if
you look at what is happening when
you're multiplying the Bernoulli case
um the bad events initially the
probability of them happening is not
it's significant if I just do two coins
two coin crosses it's quite likely that
both of the times I'm expensive in which
case I'm going after the first two time
steps with quite high probability I'm
interested in this tail probability the
the far end of the day so yeah let me
raise a question I said that the only
memory here and it's like it's two types
of memory which times that we are at
because the steps into that and the
other is like what value do we have a
single area member there is no other
memory building right and so if you're
initializing at some value
right and we are at the sum time Step
Zero or sometimes that I don't know 100
the only difference is the steps
everything
okay I think I think uh I see what
you're saying so if we think of it as
one over eight stepsiles in the whatever
case that says yes essentially what
we're doing is just running averages Etc
so if you think of the setting of law of
large numbers if you do a running
average you're not bound does not have
this Behavior it has just basically
going down but the difference is here we
have the multiplicative check for there
it is additive form so even if you're
not bound
uh
if we just have two samples I can't
lecture about the is going to be pretty
bad right once I have enough samples
then it kicks in and then I know that on
average I have got down but here because
of the multiplicative thing in the
beginning when it is not good it
actually goes
um
size is small enough so it's nice I
think that's it it starts to go down
okay good I think uh let me just show
you one more thing and then I will stop
so the result we have is actually
slightly stronger than what it showed
you this is same theorem as before I
haven't changed anything now I'm going
to change it it's the same here I will
write it differently remember there's a
probability one minus Delta and then I
have this inequality I'm just writing it
as probability of this inequality like
greater than or equal to one minus uh
Delta same thing uh but the stronger
theorem we have is that
this result and this is for a given K
any type the stronger result is that
let's fix a capital K for all time after
capital K we have this inequality as
long as I add a blow factor of log K
over 3. this is called anytime
concentration so
let's think of this pictorially earlier
I said that at any time the error with
high probability is uh less than the
dotted curve now what I'm saying is
let's blow it up by a log Factor log K
Factor then if you start then starting
from this point the trajectory that I
see is uh with property 1 minus Delta
inside this blue region
or I could start the blue thing not
there I could start it here then the
capital K also shows up then I'm I'm in
this region by just doing the small draw
Factor I'll be within this uh I think
I'll have to stop here I'll skip the
proof sketch and I'll be happy to answer
any other questions
well constant step size you don't get
exponential concentration
you do get polynomial concentration in
fact uh I mentioned srikanta where they
show that these large moments don't
exist they actually obtain the moments
till some point you can take Mark of
inequality with that you'll get
polynomial bounds this also the
dermocital paper where they get
polynomial bonds but I think it's in
similar spirit
Airlines
so this one makes it that for the second
part I assumed it's IAD so if you go
back to mean square and then think of
the IIT special case tau is basically
zero uh so all the lockdown terms
it's a different reason that you have
different reasons yes
throughout this analysis did you assume
at any point that there is a unique
fixed Point forever
yes so in the two ways you can think of
our results we are assuming it's a
contraction if it's a contraction
promises you this if it's fine you need
to fix point or we assume this unique
fixed point and we assume it's a pseudo
contraction either way
yes you just have a valley and then you
could Commerce
oh yeah I'm glad you asked because we do
have a result saying that for the first
part on mean Square uh we generalize it
for seminars right so as long as you
have a seminar then the fixed point is
actually not a point it's a Subspace and
then we show conversions to that
Subspace and we actually use this to
study average rewarding enforcement
learning because there's a development
operator this is a span server
yeah
foreign
thanks
okay thank you